okay so my interpretation of that uh
shadow minister was um you should either
work harder put more hours in or get a
better paid job
it's really hard to react to that
because it i i me you know every week
people who are in in the situation that
of the people you're meeting there just
on friday last week i went to spend some
time at a local food bank in hove the
constituency i represent and i met lots
of people who are in an extremely
difficult
time they are in jobs sometimes i met
one person who was in two jobs last week
and she's a single parent
uh the idea that she could work longer
and therefore not spend more time with
her family i think it's just
disconnected from the realities of
people's lives we had a minister last
week that said that people should be
buying more budget food
and supermarket owned brand foods you
know what we need ministers to be doing
is solving the economic problems that
family families have because of the
economic problems our country faces this
is their jobs as politicians their jobs
as politicians aren't just to tell
people to work harder work longer and go
for a promotion it's actually to accept
the reality that because of the
decisions they are making in westminster
people are no longer able to eat a
decent diet
this is the situation that we face and
there is a direct political consequences
to the priorities and decisions made in
westminster that is the reality we face
talk to me about the northern ireland
protocol and the government says or
we're being told that the government is
likely to um
rip up bits of it uh later on this week
thoughts on that prime minister of
course heading to northern ireland today
well there are lots of problems with the
approach the government are taking
firstly we're in this mess because of
the protocol that the government
designed itself and then introduced into
the negotiations and signed into
international treaty but now it is an
international treaty its domestic law
and international law if the government
unilaterally rip it up then the the our
negotiating partners not just with the
eu but the us who we're trying to sign a
trade deal with india we're trying to
sign a trade deal with all of them are
going to say can we trust the uk and the
eu will say why would we bother signing
a new deal with them uh if they're just
going to rip that up in another six
months when they don't like the new one
that they've signed with us that's the
first problem the second problem is in
northern ireland itself the politics of
northern ireland took a huge step
forward 25 years ago with the good
friday agreement and the peace process
that rests on the principle of consent
it means you need the consent of both
both communities both the unionists and
the nationalists now if the government
does something which just empowers one
side of that community you will lose the
consent so 60 percent for example of all
people elected to the empty the stormont
assembly in the recent elections stood
on a manifesto commitment to support the
protocol if the government just rips up
the protocol what will it be doing is is
over correcting from one side to the
other uh but actually whereas you might
get the dup back into the executive you
might well lose shin fein so what the
prime minister needs to do as he goes to
northern ireland today simply to parade
his failure uh of recent years uh what
he needs to do is sit down and and
summon the kind of degree of statecraft
we've not seen from him to date in order
to find a way through that can take both
communities with him it won't be
difficult it won't be it won't be easy
i'm afraid but it can be done if the
prime minister applies diligence
statecraft and graft
okay it's good to talk to you mrs keep
calling you minister don't touch shadow
thank you very much for joining us on
the program enjoy your time with your
dad thanks a lot